[Music]
humans love meat steak
fried chicken bacon pork belly and
sausages
are just the best things eating meat has
become so trivial that many people don't
consider something a proper meal if
there's no animal involved
which is pretty amazing since only a few
decades ago
meat was a luxury product today
you can get a cheeseburger for a dollar
paradoxically
meat is pretty much the most inefficient
way of feeding humans
if we look at it on a global scale our
meaty diet
is literally eating up the planet why is
that
and what can we do about it without
giving up steak
[Music]
humans keep a lot of animals for food
currently about
23 billion chickens 1.5 billion cattle
and roughly 1 billion pigs and sheep
that's a lot of mouths to feed so we've
transformed earth into a giant feeding
ground
83 percent of its farmland is used for
livestock
for example as pasture and to farm
fodder crops like corn and soy
that's 26 of earth's total land area
if we include the water we need for
these plants meat and dairy production
accounts for 27 percent of global fresh
water consumption
unfortunately meat production is like a
black hole for resources
since animals are living things most of
their food is used to keep them alive
while they grow their tasty parts
only a fraction of the nutrients from
fodder crops end up in the meat we buy
in the end
cows for example convert only about four
percent of the proteins and three
percent of the calories of the plants we
feed to them
into beef more than 97 percent of the
calories are lost to us
to create one kilogram of steak a cow
needs to eat
up to 25 kilos of grain and uses
up to 15 000 liters of water
animal products are guzzling up tons of
food but they only make up 18
of the calories humans eat according to
projections
we could nourish an additional 3.5
billion people
if we just ate the stuff we feed to
animals
to make our favorite food group even
more unsustainable
about 15 of all greenhouse gas emissions
caused by humans
are created by the meat industry as much
as by all ships
planes trucks and cars combined and
there's another aspect to meet it comes
from actual living beings
pigs cattle and chicken are not the ones
writing the history books
but if they were humans would appear as
rampant genocidal maniacs that thrive on
suffering
globally we kill about 200 million
animals
every day about 74 billion a year
[Music]
this means that every one and a half
years we kill
more animals than people have lived in
the entire 200
000 year history of humanity
one could argue that we're doing them a
favor after all
they wouldn't exist without us we might
eat them in the end
but we also provide food and shelter and
the gift of existence to them
unfortunately we're not very nice gods
a lot of our meat comes from factory
farms huge industrial systems
that house thousands of animals
engineered to be as efficient as
possible
they have little regard for things like
quality of life
[Music]
most pigs are raised in gigantic
windowless sheds
and never get to see the sun sows are
kept in pens too small to turn around
where they give birth to one litter of
piglets after another
until it's their turn to be turned into
bacon
dairy cows are forced to breed
continually to ensure their milk supply
but are separated from their calves
hours after birth
to fatten up beef cattle for slaughter
they're put in feedlots
confined pens where they can't roam and
put on weight more quickly
to make it possible to keep them so
tightly together without dying of
diseases
the majority of antibiotics we use are
for livestock
up to 80 percent in the us which helps
in the short term
but also fuels antibiotic resistances
but the ones that may have got the worst
deal are chickens
in factory farms they're kept in such
vast numbers
and so close to each other that they
can't form the social structures they
have in nature
so they start attacking each other to
stop that
we cut their beaks and claws male
chickens are deemed worthless
since they can't lay eggs and are not
suitable for meat production
so within minutes after birth they're
usually gassed and shredded in grinders
several hundred million baby chickens
are killed this way each year
even if you had a personal score to
settle with chickens how we treat them
is beyond broken so better buy organic
meat
where animals are treated nicely right
organic farming regulations are designed
to grant animals a minimum of comfort
the problem is that organic is an
elastic term
according to eu regulations an organic
hen still might share one square meter
of space with five others
that's a long way off from happy
farmyard chickens
farms that sincerely do their best do
exist of course
but meat is still a business an organic
label is a way to charge
more money and countless scandals have
revealed producers looking for ways to
cheat the system
and while organic meat might be less
cruel it needs even more resources than
conventional meat production
so buying organic is still preferable
but does not grant you moral absolution
the truth is if suffering were a
resource we would create
billions of tons of it per year the way
we treat animals
will probably be one of the things
future generations will look down on
in disgust while all these things are
true
something else is true too steak is
amazing burgers are the best food
chicken wings taste great meat satisfies
something buried deep in our lizard
brain
we hardly ever see how our meat is made
we just eat it
and love it it creates joy it brings us
together for family meals and barbecue
parties
eating meat doesn't make you a bad
person not eating meat doesn't make you
a good one
life is complicated and so is the world
we've created
so how should we deal with the fact that
meat is extremely unsustainable
and a sort of horrible torture for now
the easiest option
is opting out more often taking a
meat-free day per week already makes a
difference
if you want to eat meat produced with
less suffering try to buy from trusted
producers with a good track record
even if it costs more to make an impact
on the environment
go for chicken and pig rather than lamb
and beef as they convert their feed more
efficiently into meat
and if you're going to have your steak
you should eat it too
an average american throws out nearly a
pound of food per day
a lot of which is meat in the future
science could get us clean meat
various startups have successfully grown
meat in labs
and are working on doing so on a
commercial scale
but solutions like this are still a few
years away
for now enjoy your steak but also
respect it
and if you can make it something special
again
we have something else for you that's
also special and tastes
even better than steak we get asked a
lot how we make our videos
we thought we'd just show you cort gaza
teamed up with skillshare our favorite
online tutorial service
to teach you our unique animation style
we've just released part 3 of our
animation tutorial series where you can
learn to animate a scene from our videos
skillshare is an online learning
community with over 20 000 classes in
all kinds of cool stuff like
writing illustration and animation
with their premium membership you get
unlimited access to high quality classes
from skilled professionals
one of them is us and we also snagged a
special offer for you
the first 1000 people to use the link in
the description get two months of
unlimited access for free
if you want to learn how we animate our
videos you can start there today
[Music]